all right so black panther wakanda
forever is now out and the film is very
much about loss grief and acceptance
since Chadwick boseman's passing in 2020
the world of wakanda has had a
completely new and unexpected Dimension
added to it Chadwick was an actor that
seemed to be in the prime of his career
and though he'd had hits before there
hadn't been any that were the statue of
that first film it grossed more than the
Dark Knight did and it also earned a
nomination for best picture at the 2018
Academy Awards it catapulted him to
super stardom with both Infinity war and
endgame cementing him as a household
name however his life was tragically cut
short due to a four-year battle with
colon cancer this was an extremely
shocking death due to the actor's age
and the fact that no one knew what had
been going on with him Chadwick had
battled in silence against the disease
and for over four years he kept it a
secret that only those closest to him
knew about that means that throughout
most of his appearances in the MCU he
was wrestling with the disease and yet
none of us knew his death shocked the
creative team just as much too with Ryan
coogler having already made progress on
his black panther sequel script due to
Chadwick's death this had to be
Rewritten from the ground up with it now
in his mind that the franchise had lost
its main star and character while
wakanda forever does beautifully though
is that it doesn't shy away from this
and instead it Embraces the loss to tell
a story about grief acceptance and
moving on Sherry very much exemplifies
this and had Journey throughout polls
from the stages of grief in order to
Showcase character growth we open with a
completely black screen and her praying
to a god that she doesn't believe in it
shows just how much he's at her Wit's
End and we immediately cut to a One-Shot
take that catapult us into an extremely
tense scene in which he's trying to save
her brother like her we know there isn't
much she can do but even as an audience
member I was sat there hoping that there
was a way out unfortunately t'challa
passes away in these first few moments
and this is all done off screen normally
when a character is killed off like this
it can can feel cheap and it almost
breaks the immersion of the movie that's
because typically when actors don't
return it's normally due to contract or
scheduling problems a character on
screen will drop a throwaway lying about
why the person isn't there or will be
thrown into something where the
characters wrestle with their death all
the while though we know the behind the
scenes story which really dulls their
characters absence of passing that isn't
the case with wakanda forever though and
Chadwick's death carries a double layer
to it not only are we aware of what
really happened with him but the
off-screen death is used to strengthen
the story t'challa dies off screen
because where rooted solely ensures
perspective we don't see him pass away
because we're with her as she's working
away to try and find the Cure this is
completely heartbreaking it's rather
than being with her brother when he
passes she's in the lab instead of
saying goodbye Sherry definitely
embodies the five stages of grief in the
movie and we see her carrying them out
even before t'challa's death she has not
only denial but also bargaining in Anger
the other two are depression and
acceptance which is what the rest of the
movie is built around and we see Shiri
comes to terms with the fact that her
brother is truly gone this thematically
is what the movie is about however
there's also the Revenge cycle that we
see lace throughout it no more embodies
this too and his arrival comes at a
pivotal point in the movie after a time
Jump of the year romondo goes to Sherry
and tells her to come with her to carry
out a symbolic ritual this involves
burning the funeral robes and romonda
says that when this is carried out that
the morning stage will be at an end she
also drops a very important line and
says that carrying out this tradition is
meant to start a new relationship with
the one they lost these two lines very
much set up the post-credits scene in
which shurina only finally moves on but
she also meets t'challa's son through
him she's now become an auntie and stud
a new relationship with him through
helping to raise the Sun that he's not
going to be there for it's a really
touching moment that I want to talk more
about in just a bit but before this
shuri also has to break this cycle of
violence that she finds herself trapped
in the third act has a battle in which
the people of talocan Face Off against
the wakandans and this is used as a way
to bring the king to the surface this
leads to a battle on a beach and after
being stabbed by them all she uses the
words of killmonger to power herself up
smashing him like it's a like button she
stands over him with a spear and is
about to take his life during this point
we get flashes of romander's body lying
in the throne room and also a quick cut
of them all laughing however the scene
is something unexpected and we actually
get a rewind of all the events that have
led up to this moment through this we
very much witnessed the cycle of
violence that's built up to this point
wakanda was attacked in retaliation for
the killing of Nemours people during the
case rescue is spurred on a hatred
within him which led to the death of
ramonda this is also called sure to
think that she has to get even now too
this scene also shows us the events of
the last 500 years and also the moment
in which the more killed the colonizers
this too was an actor Revenge Anna
created a hatred with an M for the
people on the surface how about lays
throughout this moment are also flashes
of those that have been affected and
those that will be affected by the
Warren kingdoms we see the people of
wakanda just going about their
day-to-day which is also married in the
people of talocat these kingdoms are set
up directly to marry each other with
them both being empowered by vibranium
and also mystical herbs we also see
romander which is reflected in the
Moore's mother realizing that the pair
is similar and that killing him will
lead to an eternal War Shu decides not
to take his life and instead the perform
an alliance I absolutely love the lion
when she talks about how Vengeance has
consumed them and this is very much
playing upon the scene in Civil War in
which t'challa said something similar
Legends has consumed you
he's consuming them
I'm not letting it consume me Baltimore
and Zima were responsible for the death
of their parents but they wouldn't allow
this to create a murderous streak within
them in which they'd forever be on a
path of Vengeance this is very much why
she decides to go against killing him
and instead forges a piece between the
two kingdoms now after a couple of
scenes for the epilogue we close out
with shuri venturing out to Haiti to
finally burn the ropes after carrying
this out she's introduced to Designed
who we learn is t'challa's son now this
very much links back to what Rwanda said
before and how the fire ushers in a new
relationship with the one she lost
doosan is also a name that carries a lot
of meaning to it and he's named after
one of the Haitian generals who led an
uprising against the French Ryan coogler
is a master at lacing these ideas
throughout his stories and early on we
see how the French are the ones who try
and steal a vibranium from the wakandan
people when Haiti was colonized by them
to some fall back and this name brings a
lot with it very symbolic of the end and
sure he sees that brother's Legacy will
be carried on to his son who also
secretly Bears his name most MCU movies
they just have post-credit scenes that
tease something big for next time but
wakanda forever decides to do things
differently rather than being a splashy
and over-the-top teaser what's to come
you very much get an inkling of the past
what each other is Left Behind and the
fact that though he's gone he's not
truly gone now this two links back to
the line with romonda when the pair were
at the river she talked about how she
sees t'challa and everything and very
much gets glimpses of him in the rain
win and just throughout the world I've
actually often thought about stuff like
this in the aftermath of losing someone
and I think we need to remember how much
in effect people have on those around
them when they're alive they help all my
personalities way of viewing the world
and in many ways they make us so by
being alive we're carrying on their
legacy we too will affect those around
us both negatively and positively but
it'll leave a mark beneath the skin that
can carry someone were gone young
duchella is very much a representation
of this and he'll go forth with his
father's Legacy embedded within who he
is the recast each other movement picked
up steam in the wake of Chadwick's death
but I think that this is the most
respectful way that they could have
carried the character on rather than
raising him or pretending it's always
been this way the studio made a point to
embrace Chadwick's death to show how
death is very much a part of life
wakanda forever is a perfect title to
sum this up as it shows that the other
character is gone the ideas he created
and pushed are Everlasting and they'll
be carried on by those who live on in
his memory we also of course have
Chadwick's passing too and I can't think
of a better way to honor the actor by
the loss of him being laced in the very
DNA of the film every actor gives an
amazing grief written performance whilst
alls are showing us that life does go on
there are several stages of shuri
growing and advancing Beyond her
brother's death the herb she failed to
make t'challa is something she
eventually completes and this ends up
giving her powers the robes that she had
to get burned and shortly after this she
meets her nephew to me it's the perfect
wedding in the movie and obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts and what you
took from it now just to let you know
we've also launched a brand new shirt
over at xeroedition.com maybe your
romantic partner told your size doesn't
matter but sorry to spoil that myth it
does and that's especially the case if
you're a size changing superhero headed
for the quantum realm down there size is
everything so show some big Love by the
little guy with his exclusive heavy
spoiler shirt just in time for Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantum Mania and it
massively helps out the channel thanks
now if you want something else to watch
then make sure you check out one of our
videos linked on screen right now told
about loads of Marvel stuff recently and
the algorithm is working away in the
background to choose a video perfect for
you on screen right now you know that
it's it's saying it's perfect for you
and you better not be calling it a liar
hopefully I'll see you over there but if
not I hope you enjoy the rest of your
week and you have a good one mate take
care peace